Good morning Hank it's Tuesday, November 26, 2013.
I'm wearing a crumpled suit that must mean that it is time for the Bank of Nerdfighteria's semi-annual report.
So Hank, just like Toby Turner, the Bank of Nerdfighteria has two arms.
And like Toby Turner's arms, they are rock solid and growing more powerful by the year.
Let's begin with the giving arm.
So every year the nerdfighter community hosts  YouTube's Project for Awesome, a 48 hour event in which thousands of people upload videos about their favorite charities.
And then we watch and share those videos, but there's also a fundraising component to the Project for Awesome.
We raise money for the Foundation to Decrease World Suck, and then as a community we decide where to donate it,
which helps us to think about priorities and our values and the importance of being thoughtful philanthropists.
So last year we raised more than $400,000 which went to organizations fighting, among other things, illiteracy, and domestic violence, and global poverty.
So if you've never participated in the Project for Awesome now is the time! Get started on your videos for December 17th!
Ah, I almost forgot the most important thing!
Hank, you and I are auctioning off our support for World Cup 2014.
There is a link in the dooblydoo, where you can donate to the Foundation to Decrease World Suck on behalf of the team of your choice.
And we're going to support the teams that Nerdfighteria's donations choose: top to bottom.
So right now,  Germany is in 5th place, the Netherlands is in 7th place in total donations. If Germany plays the Netherlands, we are for Germany.
And I don't just mean that we will casually root for the team in question. We will watch every single game and we will wear the jersey of the teams we are supporting.
And we will endeavor to learn your soccer history and your songs and try to watch live with you on Google+ hangouts.
So please go donate. It only appears that I am pointing at my pants.
Switzerland by the way is in last place right now, so get on it Swiss people.
Also Hank, in crazy good news, the Foundation to Decrease World Suck is now an official 501C3 federally sanctioned charity.
Which means that all donations that are in the U.S. are tax deductible.
Also every dollar that you donate to the Foundation to Decrease World Suck will be matched this year up to $125,000 thanks to some anonymous donors.
Right now the Foundation to Decrease World Suck has $23,955 in the bank.
That's due to some donations from VidCon, and from the Nerdfighter Minecraft server, and some charity stuff at dftba.com.
So we're off to a really great start, much better than we were last year, but hopefully it is just the beginning.
Now I wanna talk to you about the lending arm, but first I have to get on an airplane to go see mom and dad. Hold on.
Movie Magic. Also costume change. Oh my god I'm in the exact same room where I filmed my first episode of Brotherhood 2.0 on January 2, 2007.
Only now the walls are a different color. And also painting by mom.
Okay, on to the lending arm.
Hank, over at kiva.org, the Nerdfighter group has now made more than 3.2 million dollars in loans to students and entrepreneurs around the world.
For instance, nerdfighters recently made a loan to Alvaro in Bolivia to help him pay his college tuition.
They made a loan to a woman in Samoa so she can grow a restaurant, a loan to a guy in Uganda so that he can grow his furniture business.
And there are tens of thousands of others. Through Kiva, you can make loans of as little as $25 to students and entrepreneurs in the developing world.
And 99% of the time they pay you back.
So it's basically like having a savings account with a negative one percent interest rate which is only one percent less than my bank is currently offering so it's a pretty good deal.
Plus, you get to invest in people's businesses and watch them grow.
And the coolest part is that if you're new to Kiva, your first loan is entirely free. Link in the dooblydoo.
So Hank that's the update on the Bank of Nerdfighteria.
When I was sitting here on January 2, 2007, I could never have imagined that the community that would grow out of these videos would loan more than 3 million dollars,
or that the Project for Awesome would be within shouting distance of a million dollars in total donations.
But Hank, I'm just so grateful to Nerdfighteria for making it happen. And to you.
Hank: You're welcome.
John: Heeeyyyyyy!
Hank: Reunion video!
John: Surprise reunion video!
John: Nerdfighters, again, there are links in the dooblydoo to lend and to donate.
Hank: Let's have a great Project for Awesome.
Both: DFTBA!
John: Hank, I will see you right now.
Hank: Okay.
John: Oh, and PS, here's a picture of Matt Smith doing the Nerdfighter sign with some Danish Nerdighters. Is this real life? What are you doing?
Hank: Mom collects kaleidoscopes.
John: Oh, cool.